hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen
to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome brigitte who
will speak to you more about promega and
our speakers today
thank you michelle hello also from my
side i wish you all a warm welcome to
today's webinar on a fast and reliable
method for zarzkov to waste water
surveillance
my name is brigitte zoul
and i'm the commercial lead for the
wastewater water program at promega
promega is a private biotech company
based in madison wisconsin in the u.s
and we are manufacturing reagents
instrumentation and workflow solutions
for molecular biology laboratories since
more than 40 years
promega offers products for research but
also provides solutions for clinical
diagnostics forensic genetics and
applied and environmental testing
since march 2020 we have closely
followed activities in the wastewater
based epidemiology community on
identifying methods to quantify zaskov2
in wastewater
we have actively participated in
interlaboratory evaluations such as the
first large one in the us initiated by
the water research foundation
we also received input from numerous
groups who helped us by providing
feedback on prototypes that we made
available
we learned about the challenges of
molecular testing from wastewater and
about existing methods and their
limitations for this specific target as
coronaviruses differ from waterborne
pathogens
this is by the way a good opportunity to
thank you all for your feedbacks and
suggestions that we received over the
last 18 months
so we started by developing a sensitive
and inhibitor
rtq-pcr assay specifically designed for
testing waste water samples
now testing wastewater on a weekly
routine ourselves we also experience the
pain of lengthy concentration
pre-processing methods and also realized
that reliable quantification standards
were missing to the community
leveraging our expertise from other
business areas we identified components
that were suitable to overcome the
challenge identified and further
adjusted them further
for the purpose
so well let's all warm up a little bit
and
maybe start with a short survey
so
for those who already do waste water
testing in the audience please share
with all of us how long it takes your
liberty
laboratory for receiving the sample to
get to the quantification results
so please choose
one of the options that we provide here
in the poll
okay
i see it's more than the entire working
day um let me refresh okay now we get
some more answers
okay so many of you see that it's
more than the entire working day
um well thank you
with
the solution that we have developed
we
we have we are now offering a workflow
solution that allows laboratories to
quickly implement the wastewater
surveillance testing
and
when we did the product development we
always kept in mind that there's a need
what the needs are for testing
laboratories and we try to develop a
workflow which is efficient reproducible
and also includes validation features
and that they should generate consistent
and reliable data well within a working
day
a lot of developmental work was also
dedicated to the manufacturing of
standard rnas for the qpcr essay
so we are pleased and proud to share the
insights and details about our
developments to support routine
monitoring
for for zazkov two genetic sickness in
wastewater
i will now introduce today's speakers
who will share their findings with us
we are very pleased about the
contribution from dr carlotta oliveira
who is a scientific collaborator at the
regional environmental protection agency
arpa in piermont northern italy
and during the last year her team
evaluated and implemented zlaskov 2
testing in wastewater and calotta will
share their experience and results with
us
prior to her current position she was a
postdoctoral fellow at cardiff
university in the uk where she was
working on the infection of human
papillomavirus in relation to the
development of skin cancer
thank you carlotta for putting the
presentation together and for sharing
your findings with the audience
the first talk was
the first talk will be given by
subhanjan mondal is my r d colleague who
leads the method and product development
of the wastewater kits at promega
so punjan is a senior research scientist
at promega and has been with the company
since 2012.
prior to joining promega he was a
postdoctoral fellow at harvard medical
school working on signal transduction in
init
immune response so thank you supanjan
for your great and proactive development
work during that last year
and now i give you the floor thank you
thank you brigitta
so i will talk to you about uh
uh
from a perspective of a reagent
manufacturer how we
unstudied the subject and how we
uh responded and developed tools to help
the
uh research community and
the testing labs
so wastewater-based epidemiology is the
quantitative detection of chemical and
biological signatures in
wastewater to analyze the status the
health status of a population so prior
to star score v2 uh
the the technique had been used for
monitoring uh prevalence of polio
viruses other entire viruses
as well as drugs of abuse
but uh it's real um it came to the
limelight uh with the sarskopita
pandemic
and there has been a global effort to
use uh this technique as a surveillance
tool
all over the world
so
soon after the
the virus was detected the sarco v2
virus was detected it was found that the
genetic signatures could be detected in
the human feces and so thereafter uh the
group of gert and madema from the kwr in
the netherlands uh published a work
where they were able to detect a
sarskopi to genetic material
in
the wastewater samples and that kind of
triggered the whole community to use
this method the
detection of sarsko we do from
wastewater as a surveillance tool for um
you
know
population analysis for epidemiological
purposes
and not only is the samples taken from
the wastewater treatment plants uh even
uh points uh upstream of the wastewater
treatment plants uh like uh residential
or workplace areas hospitals schools or
even like airports or even more focused
uh
individual airplanes are also being
analyzed
so this technique has a lot of potential
as a
low-cost
trending tool
and there has been a global effort in
implementing a more
concerted effort on building up
dashboards
combining them with clinical results
and it's not just a few countries many
countries here examples shown from spain
sweden the uscdc they have a program
called
nwss
and netherlands many other countries
have also as well as smaller regional
states and counties also have their own
dashboards to
make
the public aware of the trends of
wastewater and the clinical
trending
so
what is being done what is the process
what is the workflow so if
once uh the sample is collected the
sample could be collected by composite
sampling or grab sampling and then uh
the sample needs to be concentrated for
uh
the virus
the
virus concentration is kind of important
because uh
the levels of the genetic signature in
the virus is diluted because you can
imagine the level of dilution even that
happens in this sample
so
virus concentration is important and
then
extraction of the rna and then followed
by detection by either
qpcr most of the virus concentration
methods either
rely on ultrafiltration or
precipitation methods which
are electronegative membrane filtration
which have some sort of bias and we'll
talk about
that
and that impacting the variability in
the method
so before we go any further we
like to take a poll question on the
methods that you may be using currently
in your lab
so please go ahead and
fill out one of the options that are
displayed in your screen
i see the results coming
okay
so it's kind of uh
evenly distributed among the three
options that were provided so i'll move
on thank you for
all the participants who took the poll
so uh when we started with uh
testing many of the methods that we
described uh like peg precipitation uh
ultra filtration
and then we started to ask ourselves do
we even have intact viruses in the
wastewater and
the answer kind of started emerging at
that point and
what happens is the answer to that
question is no so there are
no intact viruses in the wastewater at
the point when at the time when we
analyze uh
there is no intact virus and the reason
is by the time it passes through the gut
the human gut the structure of the virus
is already compromised and then it has
to travel
days in the sewer system by that time
the membrane integrity is com almost
lost
uh and then
so we then
kind of asked ourselves if we are
not
concentrating virus particles
why are we how are we even detecting the
rna from what is uh
what is it in the sarcophagu rna that is
protecting it through the passage to the
wastewater system
so somehow it must be protected like if
you spike in naked rna in wastewater it
would be degraded in a matter of a few
hours
so what is uh it that is uh protecting
the rna so and it happens that uh
the
nucleoprotein complexes like say
nucleocapsid proteins and other proteins
that are associated with the rna is kind
of helping uh the rna
and giving some protection
so then we asked ourselves if
the virus concentration methods are kind
of um uh
using either
a size of
macromolecule particles like in
precipitation methods or
which are centrifugation based
or uh electronegative membranes which
are charged base so there is an inherent
bias and that could
be the reason
why we initially had challenges with
these methods so we wanted to
make a develop a method that
kind of
addressed all these issues and the fact
that we were also
experiencing challenges with these
methods others were also experiencing
challenges with this method
uh so our
thought process was if the end goal is
to extract nucleic acid for
qpcr anal analysis by qpcr or
other molecular methods
so
uh
it is best to extract the nucleic acid
from the get go from the sample itself
from the right away
sample itself so what we came up with is
a
nucleic acid purification method that is
more consistent
it can process
less sample volume and it can be scaled
up and down and the most significant uh
advantage that i feel was the time saver
that you can
process the entire work uh
extraction within a few hours
so what we ended up doing is combining
the virus concentration and the rna
extraction steps in
in
one
workflow
and for that we have to develop two kits
one is a manual method using spin
columns which which we term as the
wizard enviro total nucleic acid kit
using spin columns and then the next one
is maxwell rac total environment acid
kit which is a
part manual but
automated using a maxwell
automated liquid handler
so how
does this work so the first step uh here
we are using 40 ml sample that's the
typical volume that we
use it's kind of um a nice uh spot
because uh you can use
the lab laboratory 50 ml falcon tubes
for analysis so the first thing we do to
the sample is we add protease at a
protease solution and that treatment is
for half an hour so this treatment is
very important and it leads to a greater
recovery
of rna here shown in the graphs
by
ms2 which was used as a spike
[Music]
control recov recovery control here as
well as the
sarco v2 rna about
two-fold uh increase if you uh add the
protease solution so what the protease
solution does is it um hydrolyzes the
the
proteins that are associated with the
nucleic acid and protecting it so it is
releasing
the nucleic acid to the solution
then what we do is we add to that
solution a bunch of keotrops and alcohol
and what that does it is it uh
kind of
breaks the hydrogen bonding between
nucleic acid and water and makes the
nucleic acid very sticky sticky and that
it can stick to
uh matrix like a silica matrix and
that's what we do then we pass that uh
solution after adding ketobes and
alcohol isopropanol
we pass it through a
silica resin by a vacuum manifold that
many of you may be uh have used in the
past
and then the solution is the captured
nucleic acid is then
washed for removing inhibitors by
inhibitor removal like we
use like column wash one and column wash
two buffers they are basically to remove
any inhibitors that may have associated
and then uh the way to elute is just by
adding water to it so you are putting
putting back the
water and then the association with the
silica matrix just
falls and
the nucleic acid is then eluted so this
is the first step of the concentration
then we go through another step of
concentration and at that
step uh what we purified in the first
step which is like a from a 40 ml sample
to a 1ml sample that 1ml sample is then
further concentrated to
to
say 80 microliter or 40 microliter by
either a spin column as shown in the top
or by using an automated liquid handler
like the maxwell
[Music]
particle handler like the maxwell rsc
and uh
shown in the table here are some of the
recovery is the percentage recoveries
for different uh
matrix spikes that we have
tested for so for ms2 it is a
bacteriophage we've uh consistently got
around
40 uh recovery for uh coronaviruses uh
oc 43 and 229e it
was around
for
63 percent and 40 percent respectively
so uh furthermore uh depending on the
concentration of the virus in the sample
the pros uh the sampling can be scaled
up or scaled down the volume of the
sample so uh what we described before
was with 40 ml sample but it can be
scaled uh
lower with lower volume and what you
need to do is to
scale down the binding buffers
and isopropanol
accordingly and then the
if you want to scale up if the
concentrations of the virus is low then
you want to scale up the volume and then
that can also be done
the graphs below show how much nucleic
acid is extracted and there's a
proportional increase in the amount of
nucleic acid as you go higher in the
sample volume
very logical we've also tested the
workflow with sludge and suspended
solids
some countries like in canada
they have been
using sludge and suspended solids for
analysis and
that's
a sample type kind of um
does contain does associate a lot of
nucleic acid the fact being
you to understand what the sample is
so
wastewater would have urea from urine
it has
bile salts
and it also has like cellulosic material
either from tissue paper or
diet dietary cellulose so they all could
help in association to the solid so
some countries do
use sludge and suspended solids as a
sample type to analyze
so now i'll talk about some of the
customer feedback so some many of you
have provided us with comparative
results and this kind of is important
because
changing a method
in
middle of your campaign is often a tough
call
and it has to come with a
big plus it has to be done taken with
care and if it is
if the method is sensitive enough that
it can provide advantage of
using lower sample volume or better
sensitivity in prediction like maybe few
days of advance notice to your current
method those are the factors that kind
of
are critical in if you are in the
process already using a method and are
considering or hesitant to change these
are some things that are important
so this is a
data from a group in sweden uh from anna
execly
so they had started doing their
wastewater surveillance with um
electronegative uh filtration
and their method was uh very labor
intensive using a lot of sample a lot of
sample is not a concern because
the sample volume is not a concern at
all uh it is um the hands-on time that
is a concern but
however with a 40 ml sample they could
get way
more
recovery
for both
sarsko v2
signal here measured using the n1 gene
as well as a pmov which is a
physical indicator
about 20 times higher recovery than
their existing method and they uh
changed in between they changed their
method to
the direct capture method
this is another
data set from a group in
france uh from the group of jean-luc
bailly
here what they are doing is uh comparing
preg precipitation with the direct
capture using the pure yield uh columns
uh pure yield columns are the silica
columns
so here they are
uh testing for two sarskoby targets e
gene the envelope gene and the uh into
the nucleocapsid uh
gene
and for both you see that
there
the direct capture using the maxwell
method have a way higher
recovery compared to
the brake precipitation and these are
different samples and for
all the samples the direct capture
method was superior
so next um we will move on to the next
part of the talk talk which would be on
the detection part how we went about
thinking of the
right design for a qpcr
assay
and what type of internal controls one
would need to have
so as we were developing
our method and starting to share uh
prototype kits with um
with many of you uh the cdc came up with
a kind of a brief outline of a kind of a
guidance on what how to do the rna
measurement what type of analysis to
include in
such
tests so one is uh
the assays have to be quantitative
and it makes sense if you are following
trends if you are following trends over
time
which is uh unlike uh clinical testing
clinical testing is whether a sample uh
vtm tube that has uh
positive or not so that's just a yes or
no type of answer but in the context of
waste water surveillance you need quant
quantitative
measurements
so what type of controls do you need
then a way to assess inhibitors which
absolutely makes sense and then
have some internal controls like fecal
markers human fecal markers as internal
controls and of course uh
measure the sarcoby to signal so um and
we were kind of pleased to think that
the way we
were going about thinking through the
analysis aspect this was in um very much
in line with what cdc had put forward as
well
so the specific topics that i would
touch on is
the quantitative standards how we went
about making the quantitative standards
for the rtq pcr essay i'll talk about
the primer probe mix
we'll talk about the gotaq enviro master
mix the dna polymerase
and the reverse transcriptase mix
as well as how we assess for inhibition
call it as
internal amplification control or iac
and then we'll also talk about uh the
quantification of sarsko v2 signal as
well as normalization by pmmov
so first
the quantity standards how we went about
doing this so
uh what we did is we cloned the n and e
fragments of the sars cov2 genome in a
vector
pgm3 z and this vector has a t7 promoter
in it
uh we also cloned a fragment of uh the
pm mov genome that we amplify in the
qpcr assay
and we also cloned it in uh
same vector but a different vector
so then we linearize the plasmid and we
in vitro transcribed uh
to make rna the rna the
in vitro transcribe sample was then
treated with dnas to get rid of any dna
from the mix
and we quantify uh both by
fluorescent dyes as well as droplet
digital
rt-pcr
to determine the amount
of uh
rna that would correspond to 4 4 million
copies per microliter and that is what
we use we dilute the rna
to 4 million copies per milliliter and
that is used as the quantitative
standard
so we also performed some um
stability study because
one of the arguments is rnas are
not stable
and
these are rnas at very low
concentrations so we wanted to
understand
what would be the
loss of activity or if there is any uh
from repeated free stuff
so we did some freestyle experiments and
we
were pleased to find that there is
no significant loss of uh activity uh or
degradation of the rna by multiple free
stars
then uh we'll talk about a little bit
more about the primer probe mix so the
primer probe mix is a multiplexed assay
for measuring one of the sarsko v2
targets either n1 or n2 or e and this
would be detected in the fam channel
it is multiplexed with
detecting
a pmmov which is a fecal marker so that
would be in the cal4 560 which is the
[Music]
which is the
sci-5 channel
and
iac
would be in the hex channel
so the next topic is on the fecal marker
pmmov and why we use that as a process
control so
pmmov
stands for paper mild multivirus
and uh we use uh that as a human fecal
marker because it is prevalent uh
throughout uh it is like it is a
pepper virus by uh
plant virus that infects peppers but it
happens so that our the human diet diet
has evolved such that uh
this virus is present in uh
our uh digestive system and it is a good
marker for uh human fecal uh
in as a human fecal indicator for fecal
pollution
uh we chose this uh versus other uh
established markers like cross phase and
hf 193 bacteria this marker uh
because it was a rna a single standard
rna virus
that was the reason why we chose uh this
over other dna markers
um
the i iac
stands for the amplification control and
this is in
the hex channel
what it uh its purpose is to measure the
uh
the amount of inhibition
uh pcr inhibitors in the reaction
so if there is any pcr inhibitors in
your reaction the ct value or the cq
value of your reaction would have a
right shift so the trace below shows uh
the
increasing as you increase with the
humic acid here uh humic acid is used as
a
as a pcr inhibitor it's a known uh uh
reverse transcriptase and a attack
polymerase inhibitor as you increase in
the
humic acid concentration the ct value um
shifts to the right
so for no humic acid or no template
control or
nucleus free water you'll have it at
a
lower ct value and as you go higher in
the humic acid concentration
the
there is a
right shift in this city value
and this
[Music]
difference the delta between the ct
values is kind of indicative of how much
inhibitors you would have in your sample
typically we say if the
delta ct is more than two ah so compared
to the no template control that means
that you have significant uh inhibitors
present in your sample
but it is totally up to the uh user how
to define that uh
we
at this point there we do not provide
any guidance on
normalizing for that and neither
does
other
investigators who but it is useful to
know if there is a
inhibitors in the sample but
not to use that to normalize for
anything
because there is so much other variable
other factors that could also impact
so now um once
how to set up the
the standard curve and the rtq pcr
reaction so you take two microliters of
the rna standard and to uh for sar score
v2 and the pmmov uh in um
200 microliter reaction and do a 10-fold
dilution then you also have a no
temperature control which is basically a
nucleus-free water uh you also prepare
your reaction mix by mixing the
attack polymerase the gotaq
master mix
the goscript and the primer probe mix in
appropriate amount
and then make up the volume uh to a 20
micro reaction
then uh typically uh uh very typical
cycling conditions
uh and then these are uh the table below
shows kind of the uh
performance parameters for uh that four
targets for n1 into an e
and the pmov
targets for slope y intercept
efficiency and the lod of the assays
that
are contained within the multiplex
reaction
so at this point we'll uh
take a pause and take a poll uh
so please go ahead
answer this question
so do you implement process controls and
qaqc
for the wastewater analysis
okay thank you so most of you uh
have
said that you
do implement
process control process controls and qa
qc parameters some of them do not and
some want to
yes
thank you for all the participants for
this poll question
so next we'll move on to how to
interpret the data so uh in the assay
the assay as we described before uh
measures
uh one of the sarcophagu target in the
fam channel
the fecal marker in
the sci-fi channel the pmmov
and the internal amplification control
in the hex
channel
for the inhibition control
so if
you have any of the fam channel so we
have master mixes for n1
n2 and e separately
and
if any of them are positive for the fam
we would uh
imply that the sarco v2 signal is
positive so another thing to note there
is the no tempted control should be
negative so if that is negative the no
template control is negative and
there is signal from the
uh
sample that means starscore v2 is
detected
next uh if the
process controls all
show a positive signal but there is no
signal from
uh
thus
the sarco v2 uh markers that means there
is no signal and detected there are two
other
possibilities of uh invalid could be a
false positive
or
false negative where
you have
a signal from the ntc well which could
then basically mean
you have a false may have a false
positive so you repeat the qpcr assay or
you have no amplification for probably
pretty much anything any of the controls
as well as your sas kov2 signal so then
uh maybe something has gone wrong so one
uh
case where it can this can happen is
where you have not made up the volume of
the pcr reaction properly so say certain
components in the pcr reaction is not
adjusted properly
say like for example magnesium an
important component for the pcr reaction
so moving on
next we'll talk about quantification of
the analysis how how we measure viral
genome copies per liter because this
will be uh used for the trend analysis
uh copies per liter uh kind of is kind
of
generally accepted as the
unit of measure so what you'd need is
copies uh in the rtq pcr reaction
divided by the volume of uh
the nucleic acid extract that you are
using in the qpcr reaction
times concentration factor and that
multiplied by thousand for a liter
so
specifically for the copies per uh
copies in the rtq pcr that can
be determined uh based on the rtq pcr
assay and uh extrapolating from the
standard curve
the
uh volume of nucleic acid extract used
in the rtq pcr assay is uh how much you
use uh
could be five microliter of um the
extract
from your purification method if it is
five microliter then the volume in
milliliters will be point zero zero five
so that's that value
and the concentration factor is
basically uh how much are you
concentrating so if you are starting
with say a 40 ml sample and then
finally you are eluting in 80 microliter
of um
in the sample then the concentration
factor is
500 if you are eluting in 40 microliter
then it is 1000
then the next is uh normal you would
also do the same thing for both sarsko
v2 as well as pmov and what we kind of
um have been doing in practice is uh
doing a relative source cov2 signal
where we divide the star scope to uh
copies per liter or
with
the pmov signal
and that uh
kind of helps in normalizing for the
general uh
population as well as
uh any
dilution events like say uh rainfall or
um
for normalizing for events like that the
pmov signal would also be proportionally
diluted so it would is a good
normalizing tool
so uh we have been
following three wastewater treatment
plants in the den county area in
wisconsin
and this is a trace from one of the
wastewater treatment plants that we
conducted from october of
last year to january of this year
and the trace in the dotted lines is
kind of the seven day moving average of
the clinical cases and the uh trace in
bolded lines is the normalized score v2
signal and we can see
that there is a
good correlation between the
the two traces
the wastewater levels as well as the
the clinical cases
we also have published a paper on our
work which describes
what we talked about in much greater
detail
as well as
[Music]
what else can be done with the nucleic
acid like
for sequencing applications
variant analysis
and
following our publication other groups
have also published
the
second paper um is from the group
of arpa pmont in italy and you'll hear
that story in much greater detail from
carlotta
and there are other papers that are also
published and in press
and i will
end by
uh showing another example of how our
kits have been used uh for implementing
wastewater
based epidemiology and this one is from
sweden
here uh the trace in the
left is a long duration uh uh
test uh where you can see the
the spike that happened with the uh
in
the
march time frame was from the
uh the the
alpha variant
and then now it is kind of low but in
some cases uh it is spiking up the uh
trace in the uh on the right side
uh it is more um
zoomed in for some of the sites
where there is an increase in the last
few a few weeks there has been an
increase and many of them are
in uh cities or towns which are
like
university towns like umiya there is a
greater increase than
other places
so with that uh i will um uh pass the
talk to carlotta who will talk about
her work thank you
okay thank you very much uh brigitte and
mondal
so i hope you hear me well
uh
okay perfect
okay so
uh um good morning and good afternoon
everyone i'm carlotta oliveira and i'm
working at the regional center of
molecular biology
at arpa that is the environmental
protection agency of piedmont
so first of all
uh
we would like to thank uh promika and
labrut for the opportunity to
they gave us to present our experience
at this webida
and so we will present here what has
been done so far in the lab about the
saskatoon surveillance in pigment with
water samples
so a lpa arpa is the original
environmental protection agency of
piedmont it's an independent regional
independent public body with legal
technical administrative and financial
autonomy
so the aim of the agency is to control
and analyze environmental mattresses
like hair soil or wastewater
so the agency is a broad and capillary
collection activity
throughout the region for all these
environmental mattresses
including the waste water samples that
have been used
in this surveillance
okay so piedmont is an italian region
located in the north uh west of italy
uh
as a 4.3 million inhabitants and
in pittman there are 171
wastewater samples
uh wastewater treatment plants and we
have analyzed 13 out of them
so these 13 account
for much more than half of the
population living in vietnam
so so far we've analyzed 600 samples
starting from september 2020 and this
monitoring is still ongoing
the sample that we analyzed were either
grab or 24-hour composites and all the
samples of wastewater have been
maintained at four degrees
in process usually after 24 hour upon
collection
so we have followed the guidance showed
in the eu recommendation number 472
that define a common approach to
establish a systematic surveillance of
circuit 2 and its variant on wastewater
in the
eu
okay so for the analysis uh we took the
wastewater samples and extract the
total nucleic acid using the
wizard and viral total nucleic acid
and then we perform rt pcr using the
sarcop2 rtq pcr kit for wastewater
amplifying the e and the n1
gene
genes
okay so for setting up the protocol in
the lab we have a
a specificity test
and we run a three three test so in the
first one we have sparked the oc 43 and
the two to nine e
in the form tml of water then in the
second one
uh other than the oc 43 and the 229e we
also spiked in the circle two rna and in
the third one uh we only added um the
sarscop2 rna into
water
so as a result
we have obtained amplification only in
the solution where the subscribe to rna
was spiked in
and not in the other solution
okay so the data resulted for the
monitoring have been published
last august on
the journal environmental research
for this paper we focused on four main
wastewater treatment plants
that are
highlighted in circle on the map
in the period of the monitoring was
august uh
2020 to july 2021
okay so here we have plot the ct values
of saskatoon
uh derived from the analysis performed
on the for wastewater treatment plants
on the period from august 2020 to july
2021
so as you can see
uh there are two clear and separate
peaks one in the period of october
november 2020
and the other one in march april 2021
sorry
where the
second and the third way
waves were in place in italy during this
that time
okay so in order to see if there was a
temporal correlation between the e gene
of circle 2 and the cova 19 cases
we have plotted here the two curves
together so the blue dr one
represent the curve of ejin
city derived from the wastewater sample
and the gray one is the curve of
covenant in cases per hundred thousand
inhabitants that uh related to the
population served by that wastewater
treatment plant
so as you can see there is a temporal
correlation between the presence of
sarcop2 rna in wastewater in the
kovin-19 prevalence data
so the wastewater data definitely
preempt and anticipate the trend of the
disease for all the considered sites
okay so the monitoring is still ongoing
so after july and here are plotted the
data from the e and n1 sarscop2 genes
for therefore wastewater
treatment plants analyzed
so again
here it's clearly visible the first peak
of october november 2020
also the one
in april march 2021
and
now
these are the data from last week so
there is a tendency of a decrease in
city value
and so an increase of the presence of
the circle to virus in the wastewater
treatment plants
so this monitoring is still ongoing and
our agency arpa is sending this data to
the regional health authority for
further evaluation
okay so the monitor is still ongoing but
we have some work in progress
that we are working on
so we are planning to quantify the
sarcopte and the peppermill motor virus
that
subian already mentioned
on the wastewater samples using the
standard curve method
also
so the peppermint model viral is a fecal
marker and also that will help
in the normalization of the data
moreover
we would like to apply for the
accreditation the iso
17025 that define the general
requirement for the competence of
testing and calibration laboratories
and also the last work in progress is to
sequence subscop2 and
analyze its variant
that populate the the wastewater sample
so on this regard we have some
preliminary results that we would like
to show you
okay so for the preparation of samples
that uh reach and they have high quality
in order to be sequenced
we use the the same kit that we used
before for the extraction of the total
nuclei acid for from wastewater
so this is the wizard and viral total
nuclear acid kit
then we treat the sample with the dnas
and we further perform a step of
concentration and purification with the
using the aurelia preparing a cleanup
and concentration system
okay so
um
we compare uh to extraction uh
in the bottom one you see the filter
sample so we collect the wastewater
sample then we filter the sample uh
twice so first with a 0.45 micrometer
filter
and then second with that 0.25
micrometer filter before adding the
protease
and in the top one we
just collect the waste water sample and
we
didn't filter the sample so we just
treat with protein solution
so after the
the extraction then we quantified
using the standard curve method the
the rna input
for the library
preparation
okay briefly i will show you the
library preparation so
after the rna purification in qc
we
perform a reverse transcription step in
which we uh transcribe the rna into cdna
then we
target a amplification specifically for
subscribe
and then we digest the sample and run a
second
pcr reaction for indexing and
amplification
then we perform quality control and then
we run the sequencing
so the the data then were biologically
uh bioinformatically analyzed using a
sophia genetics
software
okay so as we expected the output was
really different between the two
approaches in term of rates aligned to
the sarcopte genome
so there were many more rates in the
filtered sample as you can see in the
bottom
uh
and whereas in the top one the
non-filter
there were
less reads that were aligned to the sars
contour genome
but the total amount of reads were
nearly the same between the two samples
so as you can see the uh
in the top the non-filter sample there
were a total rates of 8.69
whereas the filter one there are total
rates around 7.93
so we were wondering if the off target
rates
were sequenced and and for doing that we
perform a metagenomic analysis
so in the meta genomic analysis the
output rates
are aligned to all the genomes that are
known to perform the taxonomic
classification
so as we expected in the
non-filtered samples so the top one
um
there are 92 percent of the reits
that that are the output of the
sequencing that align to 92 bacterial
genome whereas in the bottom one so the
filter sample there were 61 percent of
the reits that are aligned to
the susceptible
genome so we plot these uh data on a
graph and and so that
more if more than 40 percent of the
reads out of the metagenomic analysis
aligned to the circle to genome will
serve more than 90 percent of genome
comrades
so whereas in the case of the
non-filtered samples so the blue one
there was only 30 percent of um
genome coverage because the
reits that aligned with two
sarcophagus were only the zero point
eight percent
moreover and most important
if the genome coverage is higher than 90
percent and there are more than 40
percent of the effective rates that are
the rates used to call the variant
we could define the lineage
of the most abundant variant in the
sample so here we were able to define
the lineage of all the samples that were
filtered
so as a conclusion
based on our experience we can say that
the promega kits we used were reliable
easy to use and useful for our aim
and moreover they can be used for the
environmental monitoring of sarcopte in
wastewater samples and also they can be
applied for downstream high throughput
analysis
last i would like to thank our
collaborator at the university of turin
and all the people in the
arpa agency and all the people of the
molecular biology lab that run the
monitoring and the sequencing
and you for your attention
thank you
thank you very much carlotta and
for your presentations
we have time for
some questions and there are already
many questions in the chat so thank you
for being such an active
audience here
um i have two questions
regarding the normalization
so the first one is do we have any idea
about the pmmov distribution amongst
population
there doesn't seem to be so much
publication
um is there um supanjan do you want to
answer to that please so uh the pmmov uh
as of a human fecal marker has been well
studied since the 1990s
and there are many publications on um
the wide spread
[Music]
so
the concept is kind of
intriguing and counterintuitive like how
could a plant virus be a human fecal
marker but
the way human diet has evolved over the
last um maybe say 100 years
the prevalence
of the
pmmov in human diet
has been shown to be a good
marker for
the human fecal
pollution
thank you spanjan
there's a second question in this regard
so um if and i don't know if that was
the case for you maybe carlotta have you
considered to use the flow rate of the
water also to normalize have you used
that or did you go with pmmov right away
yes so
we we
use the ppmov also to
our in control for
for for
uh
to see in order to see if there was a
dilution of the sample maybe
uh caused by the rain as uh also subian
said
so yeah we are we are planning also to
quantify the ppmov
and to use for normalization of the data
yeah thank you i know that many groups
are doing it this way
as well so thank you
there's one question if there is an
available method like a control for the
extraction step
i know that
both of you have done some testing
uh with spikes
while implementation does one of you
want to comment on that maybe
yeah i can go first yeah so for
the
matrix spike
so the way we uh
dealt with it is um
there was no consensus uh like um
what on what virus to use
and we have
tested for
uh
comparative analysis uh
coronaviruses human coronaviruses oc43
and 229e and so has carlota used some of
the coronaviruses
but uh due to like challenges of
culturing maintaining and using that as
a
for a starter lab we have mostly used
ms2
and for most purposes it serves serves
uh the need
so
like
like but it is entirely up to the
uh user on what uh uh best to use uh
yeah because
different people are using different uh
meditation then
in the ring trials that we've taken part
in
all ring trials were
either width
spiked they were either spiked with a
coronavirus
from the
organizer the ring trial organizer and
they had also asked us to spike
with
any other uh
matrix spike that we are using in the
lab
um
and
so
there are publications on
some there's some guidance on what to
use
thank you
i see that we are up the hour now thank
you very much i think we have to
finish this session
thank you very much to the speakers and
for everyone attending and staying with
us for this one hour
i wish you all a great continuation of
your day and thank you for attending
again thank you bye bye